you complain about us being divided and
then you immediately start using Chinese
government communist propaganda talking
points to attack our commander-in-chief
omits according to your own definition a
pandemic who has the Americans best
interests at heart what do we think
about just taking a corona pact where we
all look a popsicle stick I'm in I think
it over with we're gonna get it get it
no wait isolate it get immunity and
you're free and I'm just hoping that I'm
like you know Tom Hanks and his wife or
Justin Trudeau's wife and eaters Elba or
any of the NBA or NFL players and that I
get it and I have no symptoms there you
go yeah wait is this a ploy for you guys
tax is there any public figure who has
gotten it and have severe symptoms did I
know I know I don't think you're gonna
hear about it yeah oh you're something
go say so I don't think they want to say
it I mean may they may say it later
I bet you'll hear someone who was like
oh you know I had it it was pretty bad I
just didn't want to let it freak you out
yeah and was especially I would think
it's in the higher levels of government
they're not they're gonna do the rest
not to say anything right
right you know it's gonna create a panic
yeah I mean you mean more so than
already 30 days it's gonna get who is
your source because we all saw that
morning half-asian bill said hey by the
way Donald Trump's gonna declare
national emergency two o'clock today he
told me to go get gas and I did and he
was you were off by 12 minutes yes uh-uh
it was it was a little delayed how did
you know that you know you know things
you hear things we have a full Thursday
show worked up for you but wanting to do
my part I will have my personal doctor
dr. Choi on the show tomorrow which is
great because he is Asian he's Korean
he's very funny and he's very
knowledgeable he's on the American Board
of endocrinology and he's been he's out
there in Vegas where they just had
unfortunately the first death and now
spreading and I think he's a good voice
right now is a reasonably wilderness
because he's a very level-headed doctor
I like him a lot he uses experimental
methods like he's really kind of at the
cusp of stem cells but if you go and
he'll say listen this is what it maybe
works for I'll say this is what it may
be work work for and not back so some
help like he goes this is this is where
do I go this stem cells really help you
go well
in Europe for like acute joint but some
people they say you take stem-cell help
everything but look I bred my knee I
tell my ACL okay yeah and a half yeah
and a half can't walk then for weak stem
cell you tell me and there are a wide
range I should say there are oh I
shouldn't start off improperly there
there's a wide range of opinions on the
coronavirus case some people think that
the quarantines of closures are over
killed we're shutting down too much the
economy others think we're not doing
enough that there can be no overreacting
where do you line up and right now the
blame game is going around a lot of
people blaming President Trump some
people blaming the media who do you I
will tell you China Chinese government
full stop yep don't trust China oh yes
we're never spoken right from on my
cousin Wang what a guy he's amazing look
at him what an anus here's something I
understand this is a time where
hopefully we can come together as
Americans just to try and do the right
thing we need to protect those who are
vulnerable oh really that's older people
people with pre-existing conditions yeah
most young people who are healthy you're
probably going to get it it's not going
to be that severe that's what we know
thus far but it could change here's what
really bothers me I'll tell you this
let's say Donald Trump had done
everything wrong okay
right let me clarify this too I'm not
gonna be shamed into panicking this is
something else do people get mad at
panic nope yeah that's not gonna happen
I'm going to react as genuinely as
humanly possible let's assume that
Donald Trump did everything wrong don't
like that's the case but let's assume
that I still don't like the media
carrying the water of the Chinese
government's propaganda which is what
we're seeing right now I don't care if
with Barack Obama Jimmy Carter Bill
Clinton no sorry that's my president
that's Communist China my team your team
end of story yeah cut and dry so as a
woman virus right now it's it's
spreading beyond China um we've seen a
huge shift to and how the media is
covering it so this is something a lot
of people need to remember turns to know
the right wing they were saying don't
worry about it yeah no no no no no it
wasn't a left-right thing look at
BuzzFeed look at New York Times right
here they were the one saying that it
wasn't much to worry about they it was
it was them wasn't it wasn't a common
cold when
then they pivoted now that it serves
their interest - trying to blame Donald
Trump for this pandemic and that's also
why people don't believe you will come
back to that you know there is value in
times like these where people should
hopefully be able to trust the media but
when you say it's not a big deal don't
worry about it and then you only say
it's a big deal because it's Donald
Trump's fault of course people don't
believe the same folks who said Russia
Gate and prostitutes on furniture we
don't believe you and you have done the
public a disservice so let's start along
the trail here to kind of go through it
this is kind of started with them the
virtue signaling that we've seen of
reporters late night hosts all of a
sudden now you've seen this they're
saying that it is racist to refer to the
coronavirus kovat 19 for those in the
medical known as the Wuhan virus tie and
coronavirus to China and Chinese people
isn't just a racist dog whistle it's a
whole racist Orchestra it's a mighty
mighty racist Boston time others have
criticized you for using the from your
Mighty Mighty Bosstones virus continue
using that phrase I have to call it
where it came from it did come from
China so I think it's a very accurate
term no it's not it's a very racist term
calling this the Chinese virus there are
reports of dozens of incidents of I
advise against Chinese Americans in this
country your own a secretary news RSS he
does not use this term because ethnicity
does not cause the virus I have a great
high of great love for all of the people
from our country but as you know China
tried to say at one point maybe this
stuff now that it was caused by American
soldiers that can't happen it's not
gonna happen not as long as I'm
president
it comes from China she got
with the fact that she's trying to carry
the water of the Chinese propaganda
China and I go through how many
erroneous things happen in all those
clips yeah one it's gonna be Bork astre
had no Asians in it battle sure we do
call things by where they're coming from
that's how you distinguish them it's a
very common thing it's not racist memory
since when was being Chinese a race
waitin what so now Chinese is not a race
all types of races in fact there are all
kinds of people of all kinds of
different nationalities that live in
China deliver why do you look like a
racist character it's a little small and
my arms are close together when I get
suspicious I squint my eyes they're
already squinted can people tell when
I'm suspicious we'll get to most of them
and I want to lay out the case as to why
there's a lot of blame at the foot of
the Chinese government not the people I
feel horrible for the people that
they've been oppressed for so long we'll
get to that here's something interesting
though up until this point the media had
no problem
using the term Wuhan virus the total
number of deaths from the Wu hen
coronavirus it's now surpassed the SARS
outbreak from 2002 to 2013 little from
the West villages fast as the number of
confirmed cases of the Wu hen virus
continue to serve the 34 year old
ophthalmologists diagnosed Saturday with
the Wuhan corona virus if new
information about how the Wuhan corona
virus is spread good to have you with us
so we start with the Wuhan corona virus
spreading across China on a corona virus
have now been confirmed in big most
Chinese regions and that was actually
there are now 11 confirmed cases of the
Wuhan corona virus and so you wonder why
earlier on this program we said it could
get worse maybe not we don't know yet as
well as we should
where it actually stems from well it's
because of you lest you forget for the
purpose of consistency I don't want to
it could get bad at some point yes I
don't want you to go back here and say
you said it wouldn't ever get but it
could get bad if we're going to be
naming the virus based on its source
wouldn't
climene us ask virus be more a virus to
be more accurate you know and just like
you said we do this all that there are
other diseases that are geographically
named we have what we have a Spanish flu
West now people don't know Ebola Zika
Lyme disease German measles not to
mention the ill named Polynesian island
of Lou Gehrig we know that all of these
places great oceans blue seas is there
anybody that actually think of AIDS
that's a horrible name for a county is
there anybody out there who actually
thinks that Donald Trump was saying that
all Chinese people are responsible for
this that's that's the worst premise
I've ever seen for this argument well
and this is what's so concerning to me
is you have to wonder is it disingenuous
are they really trying to use this
simply as a tool for scoring political
point and here's something important now
the Chinese govern they started shifting
the blame trying to say that they did a
great job containing the virus and that
maybe it didn't even come from from ooh
ham don't trust China official policy
put that on the house so who decides to
echo this Bloomberg News they were in
peace is praising China's handling of
the outbreak the New York Times ran a
piece claiming that China bought us time
and that we were the ones who squandered
it the Washington Post they reported the
Trump was quote stoking nationalism by
emphasizing the country where the virus
originated calling it the Wu Han virus
Lodging conspiracy theories about it
being deliberately weaponized and
accusing the Chinese of a cover-up but
it did originate in mu Han and there was
a cover-up in China did not buy us time
they did the opposite of that so this
isn't just the blame game here where
you're trying to say it's their fault it
matters because we need to understand
how to deal with this in the future and
that doesn't just mean saying hey the
CDC needs to do their part we need to
hold the media accountable so yeah let's
assume and I think rightfully so that
China is not to blame for creating the
virus they are certainly to blame for
covering up and misleading the world yes
several whistleblowers tried to raise
awareness about this early on in dissent
one of them was that was doctor am i
pronouncing this right doctor li wen
Liang yep let's see pandemics bringing
us together oh so what are the Chinese
government and what are the media do
they forced him to recant under threat
they made him sign a document saying
that his behavior was illegal smeerdom
in the media isolated him and conditions
that ultimately led to unfortunately the
man dying of the virus well a man who's
become incredibly well known around the
world because of the corona virus has
died this is the Chinese doctor who
tried to warn the medical community
about the corona virus he was told to be
quiet by the authorities before weeks
later being diagnosed with the virus
himself Frank I don't think that
newscaster would know do you think it is
being quieted just a euphemism for like
spiked bat to the face when have we
decided that a nation who's had its
entire history based on human rights
violations is the paragon of truth right
on how people are suffering or not
suffering so the left the years think -
that's important the left in the United
States now they've been celibate they
were celebrating these whistleblowers by
the way when they thought it was just a
story about a foreign virus in some
distant land in China all of a sudden
once it arrived in American shores
everything changed they started praising
China and its handling instead of
highlighting its gross incompetence and
by the way simultaneously right now
they're placing the blame squarely at
the feet of President Trump and this is
not we want to be closer than just an
isolated incident a few whistleblowers
being silenced okay some were just this
week we learned there was a Wu Hamlet is
it will Han or Wu Han Luhan then I said
it wrong because they were saying whoa
huh huh huh huh huh well huh so just
this week we learned it was a well it
was a Wuhan lab that identified the
corona virus in December it was ordered
to stop testing and destroy the samples
China is now trying to censor the story
China is now even expelling banning if
you need to synonym Western journalists
who've reported on their incompetence
which is again why we say Donald Trump
don't trust China China is so a little
flowery I think you could be quicker to
the point
and by the way what we're talking about
media please do hit the notification
bell hit all notifications if you're
watching this on youtube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
these days and do consider joining
Michael that's the only thing that
allows us to continue creating this kind
of content not beholden to Al Jazeera or
a foreign caliphate and new videos every
day
9:00 p.m. Eastern here's another point
that really matters not only about the
cover up China could have prevented this
yeah it's not just about the blame game
it's again it's about the opportunity
cost and ultimately that that was people
that's people's lives if China had not
covered it up that I mean the Chinese
government the Chinese people are just
as much a victim of the Chinese
government as anybody else meaning the
entire world that's what bread and emic
means as far as I understand it it could
have been prevented so here's some
recent reports that actually show China
had its first confirmed cases of
coronavirus as early as November okay
and then there was a recent study that
showed that if China had enacted
measures after the whistleblowers
warning rather than hitting with a
two-by-four a nail through it they could
have prevented 95% of the virus cases
Wow but they didn't they stopped testing
they destroyed the results they silenced
whistleblowers they even refused help
that was offered them by the World
Health Authority and the CDC they worked
the CDC was not allowed in and so it
became a global pandemic
donnaught run don't trust China so
trigger-happy we get it less true on the
seventh time than the first it so here's
the thing where's the digging if we're
talking about Donald Trump we want to
blame him for the CDC again tomorrow I'm
going to have my dr. Choi on the show
who's actually a certified practitioner
who's had to deal with this he's my
personal doctor and he's Asian he said
Koreans will be an interesting
perspective but while we're blaming
Donald trum for this media where's the
digging we're talking about China
whistleblowers that stuff gives you a
raging erection most of the time where's
the Erin Brockovich scenario it's
undeniable 95 percent of this could have
been presented prevented it had China
just not only not lied but not
physically harmed the people who are
trying to save the rest of the
old it doesn't mean that the United
States handled everything well but we
certainly know that it was handled with
malice and ill intent over there with
the Chinese government and what happened
what happened with try it here's where
we are right now at break chart they
what is it communist fascist regime
gonna communist fascist regime they
start sending in police forcibly
throwing people into quarantine now
against their will that's where they are
that's terrifying
it really is they know if you go to the
hospital you don't come back this is why
I like the fact that America is a
melting pot because you trust one Obama
phone lady in there it's a very
different expression China is what is it
the that the nail is six up gets
hammered down right yeah and these
people live in fear and so American
journalists guess what you are enabling
the oppression of Chinese people by
doing this they can't stand up for it
instead you're too busy blaming Trump if
this is not an absolute disaster and
pandemic it will be while we're talking
about them politicizing it which is
unfortunately what I've already done it
will be a disaster for Democrats it will
be a disaster for the left unless this
becomes an extremely fatal
uncontrollable scenario yes since that's
what they predict and they tried to pin
that on Trump it will be bad for them
that's horrible they have a vested
interest in that being the case again
just talking about people acting in
their own self-interest let's assume
that Donald Trump is acting exclusively
in itself interesting he doesn't care
about the American people
I don't but let's assume that and let's
assume that Wolf Blitzer is doing the
same one says read my lips this is going
to be a disaster the kind of which
you've never seen we're going to see
fatalities the kinds of what you've
never experienced and and it this is why
the media's job is so important and then
you have President Donald Trump saying
we're doing everything that we can take
these proper precautions we're going to
get it under control these people have a
vested interest in being held to their
word just like if Democrats are the
party of the port's in their best
interest to keep you poor if
public into the party of the rich they
need a fifty percent plus voting block
teleporter and this is where this is
what really bothers me about this there
there would be some serious value in
having trust in the media right now and
knowing where to turn and get accurate
information but it's hard after the
Russia hoax the Covenant kids the
Kavanagh rape hoax is Jesse smaller the
list goes on
you're the little boy who cried
coronavirus I guess you cried Donald
Trump now you said it again it's
anonymous like shrunk I wish I
desperately wish that we could trust
someone in the media right now wouldn't
it be nice to live they're telling the
truth but and this is why Americans
don't trust you because you immediately
tied it with President Donald Trump you
complain about us being politically
divided in this country man I understand
and that's a problem man some facets
another facet I think it's a good thing
so that we know where we line up but in
a time like this we should be coming
together to try and keep the most
vulnerable among us protected you
complain about us being divided and then
you immediately start using Chinese
government communist propaganda talking
points to attack our commander in chief
Amit according to your own definition a
pandemic who has the Americans best
interests at heart
the worst thing you can do right now is
try and weaponize this politically and
not just and I'm not saying that for
Donald Trump I'm saying that for the
American public and ultimately for trust
in our institutions you're shooting
yourself in the foot
so we don't know what's gonna happen not
making predictions but my god I hope I
hope that at least some folks here or in
control of information stop siding with
it Communist Chinese propagandist
government guess who I am
I'm Josh Hartnett bet you didn't think
you'd see that face in a while this is
what we call an end card which is where
I tell you that you should subscribe if
you like this video or click one of
these other videos that you may like I
hit the notification bell of course join
mug club because that's what allows us
to continue doing these videos and just
so you know YouTube actually is created
a new policy where they might start
outright banning channels that are no
longer commercially viable
which means that this is merely a
figment of your imagination